madame la présidente madame la ministre
Messieurs les Présidents Madame et
Monsieur les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues nous nous retrouvons
aujourd'hui pour étudier l'un des textes
les plus importants de cette mandature
et je suis très fier d'être devant vous
pour le défendre c'est un texte
ambitieux et qui prouve la volonté de
notre majorité de travailler avec tous
ceux qui veulent honnêtement préparer
notre pays pour atteindre nos objectifs
climatiques les défis sont immenses et
notre retard est déjà très important
nous n'avons pas le choix est-ce utile
de rappeler pourquoi car même si nous
consommons moins d'énergie ça a déjà été
rappelé nous aurons besoin d'environ 60%
d'électricité en plus d'ici 2050 par
rapport à aujourd'hui
parce que aussi le nucléaire ne suffira
pas
faire sortir de terre des centrales
nucléaires prend du temps beaucoup de
temps et en même temps 12 réacteurs
arriveront en fin de vie en 2035 nous
n'aurons donc pas le temps nécessaire
pour satisfaire nos besoins en
électricité qu'avec du nucléaire parce
que le nucléaire coûte cher très cher
près de 52 milliards d'euros pour la
construction de 6 pairs 2 sur une durée
de 25 ans
parce qu'un scénario 100% nucléaire se
heurterait à la faisabilité
technologique et industrielle selon la
filière elle-même il existe une forme de
plafond de capacité industrielle de 14
réacteurs nucléaires nouveau à horizon
l'heure est donc à l'action en mettant
un grand coup d'accélérateur au projet
d'énergie renouvelable en France les
quatre-viens éoliennes en mer voient à
peine le jour en France alors que 5700
tournent déjà en Europe
l'Europe certains nous diront d'ailleurs
qu'il s'agit d'une raison à nos mots
pourtant les propositions populistes et
europhobes soutenant une sortie de la
France du marché européen de l'énergie
ne sont pas des solutions viables et
soutenables nous le savons tous je ne me
souviens pas avoir entendu cette
critique lorsque la France était
exportatrice nette sortir de ce marché
ne nous permettrait pas plus de garantir
notre approvisionnement énergétique le
réformé oui en sortir non
oui l'unique solution est de produire
plus d'énergie sur notre sol nous
travaillons sur ce texte depuis
plusieurs semaines avec tous ceux qui
partagent ce constat et qui comme nous
au groupe démocrate souhaite accélérer
nos procédures d'implantation
aujourd'hui il faut 5 ans pour un parc
solaire 7 ans pour un parc éolien 10
lorsqu'il est en mer alors que dans les
pays scandinaves il n'en faut pas plus
de trois ans malgré la crise covid cela
Mesdames et Messieurs chers collègues
nous ne pouvons nous y résoudre les
sénateurs ont à ce titre largement
riches au texte pour le voter à la quasi
unanimité car en effet pour adapter nos
modes de vie au dérèglement climatique
ainsi préserver une qualité de vie à nos
enfants un consensus peut vite être
trouvé
je m'appelle donc ici solennellement à
nos collègues des républicains si vous
ne voulez pas passer pour des anti
énergies renouvelables comme vous
semblez le craindre emboîtez le pas de
vos collègues sénateurs et construisez
avec nous ce texte en responsabilité je
ne doute d'ailleurs pas je ne doute pas
d'ailleurs que les 1000 et quelques
amendements déposés par votre groupe y
contribueront pleinement
aussi je tiens à souligner la qualité
des débats que nous avons eu en
commission apaisé constructif avec
l'ensemble des groupes politiques grâce
à l'engagement à l'esprit de
co-construction de nos quatre
rapporteurs que je salue ici mais
également à l'investissement au sérieux
de notre ministre qui peut se targuer
d'un travail trans partisan de qualité
j'ose espérer que cet esprit perdurera
dans les débats en séance publique où le
regain de visibilité a malheureusement
parfois tendance à exacerber la volonté
de certains de tout conflictualiser de
grâce gardons l'esprit constructif qui a
prévalu en commission oublions pour un
temps sur ce texte qui engage l'avenir
de nos enfants cette politique spectacle
qui abîme tant notre institution
je pense notamment au dispositif de
planification territoriales en jeu
central de ce texte et réacteur de la
réussite d'un projet si nous considérons
que le droit de veto des mers proposé
par les sénateurs n'étaient pas la
solution nous souhaitons placer des élus
locaux au cœur de ce dispositif nous se
tiendrons donc la proposition d'une
conférence territoriale réunissant mère
et président de PCI au sein de laquelle
seront arrêtés l'ensemble des zones
d'accélération préalablement
identifiés par les communes pour
implanter ces projets d'énergie
renouvelables aucune commune ne pourra
se voir imposer une zone qu'elle n'aura
pas identifié préalablement
nous nous assurerons de la nonne
artificialisation des sols et de
l'effectif réversibilité des
installations agrivoltaïques en imposant
des garanties financières nous proposons
que ces projets puissent être portés
exclusivement par des agriculteurs enfin
ce texte doit permettre à chaque citoyen
de se saisir de ces enjeux c'est
pourquoi nous saluons et poursuivrons le
travail en séance pour diversifier au
maximum nos sources de production
méthanisation géothermie hydrogène
réseau de chaleur et de froid
l'accélération partout cela est possible
mais également l'autoconsommation en
simplifiant les démarches pour faciliter
la création de société de projet par
exemple il est rare de pouvoir se
targuer d'avoir travaillé sur un texte
de cette importance un texte qui marque
une inflexion non pas pour le
quinquennat à venir mais pour des
décennies il y a de cela près de 40 ans
nos prédécesseurs ont défini la
politique énergétique de notre pays et
nous bénéficions encore aujourd'hui de
ces retombées positive nous avons la
même responsabilité aujourd'hui c'est
non seulement une responsabilité pour
nous-mêmes mais aussi pour nos enfants
pour notre pays et pour l'Europe pensons
au bien commun dépassons nos clivages
habituels et votons ce texte je vous
remercie
merci